oh god this is terrifying as
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's episode we will be looking
into the diet of euphoria it girl alexa
demi but first let me tell you about my
sponsor caesar so my dog poppy is like
family so obviously we want to feed her
the best food that we can she loves
caesar wholesome bowls and simply
crafted wet dog food because they've
been crafted with gourmet culinary
inspired ingredients that pet parents
like us can see and trust real meat is
the first ingredient plus wholesome
fresh vegetables so my little fur baby
can get in on family meals similar to
what i've been feeding my human kids
wholesome bowls contain no artificial
flavors colors fillers or preservatives
and simply crafted is the perfect topper
with less than six ingredients poppy
races to her bowl when she knows that
it's meal time and she like inhales her
food faster than i've ever seen before
wet dog food is particularly also great
for these really hot summer months when
they need the extra hydration so i
recently partnered with caesar to
develop a pet parent recipe inspired by
the gourmet ingredients in wholesome
bowls and simply crafted and now i can
enjoy yours and their shared meal time
experience with poppy and you can too so
check out my recipe and sign up to
receive a bestie box with a free sample
of caesar wholesome bowls or simply
crafted by visiting caesar
caesarbestieballs.ca and of course you
can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my general
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating we
will be discussing a pretty extreme
crash diet so please skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that sub button and follow me over on
tick tock and instagram abby's kitchen
so if you are not familiar with alexa
demi i'm not sure what you've been doing
all pandemic but i have been binge
watching euphoria on repeat so alexa
plays the fiery maddie and is known for
her character's makeup hair clothes and
by association her body and youtuber
bianca monboy tried her diet for five
days so let's take a look how she did on
today's video we are going to be putting
ourselves through suffrance for an
entire week to try the one and only
alexa demi's hardcore diet while taking
her popular hardcore classes
i think we know where this is going but
let's take a look at what she eats in a
week we've seen her body look amazing in
all of her wardrobe outfits in euphoria
her stomach is super flat and i just
want to know if this actually works ah
yes the allure of the flat stomach the
unicorn that every woman online seems to
chase i want to just remind everyone
that washboard abs is not a healthy goal
for most women ab definition doesn't
generally happen above 20 body fat which
also happens to be around the body fat
percentage associated with reproductive
and hormonal imbalance not to mention
it's very normal for your stomach shape
and size to change throughout the course
of the day as you put food and drink
inside it so please can we stop
pathologizing non-flat stomachs for the
second disclaimer this might not work
for all of us we can really all be
eating the same thing and i might be
losing weight slower than other people
who are trying the same exact thing and
that's because all of our bodies are
very very different so really pay
attention to your body if you are trying
to diet don't just rely on that diet
make sure whatever you're trying you are
also taking notes of how did it make you
feel did it make you blow yes to
listening to your body yes to asking
yourself how did that make you feel but
is did the diet make me bloat really the
most important question on whether or
not you should continue a crash diet
probably no like can we add disclaimer
number three in here that you shouldn't
copy a celebrity's diet plan fyi a lot
of the euphoria co-stars have allegedly
had to manipulate their diet to meet the
aesthetic of the show and some have
allegedly struggled with disordered
eating patterns in the past as well so
please let's not jump on that bandwagon
so fast i'm going to be measuring my
waist and my stomach and my lower belly
just to see if my stomach can change in
just one week so i wouldn't put too much
stock in a week's worth of measurements
most physique coaches will recommend
measuring yourself every two weeks or so
and ideally a few days worth of numbers
just to compare because it's normal for
women's waist circumference to fluctuate
significantly within and between days so
if there were any significant changes in
that one week alone it would probably be
likely from dehydration and physical
lack of food in the gut so for breakfast
we're gonna be having two porched eggs
poached eggs one avocado and green juice
[Music]
so this is a good start we've got some
high quality protein in the eggs some
healthy monounsaturated fat and fiber in
the avocado and some micronutrients in
the juice but earlier in this video
bianca said that alexa would start her
day with 40 minutes of cardio followed
by a killer ab routine
so if this were to be a post-workout
meal this would very likely not be
nearly enough we're looking at just 14
grams of protein and an insignificant
amount of carbs when we ideally want to
see 0.25 to 0.4 grams per kilogram of
protein every three to four hours plus a
one to three to four ratio approaching
to carbs post-workout and that's in
order to help maximize recovery and
muscle growth so yeah now i'm
understanding why bianca affectionately
described this as a week of suffering as
her evening snack she likes having
fruits so we're gonna have some fruit
look at my plate of fruit i feel like
naturally fruit never really fills me up
so bianca is kind of following this meal
plan in her own order which i am not
going to police because nothing makes
sense about these nonsensical bad diets
anyway i mean nothing they do makes any
sense i'm just glad that we got some
energizing carbs in this snack now more
interesting to me is that we started off
this video calling the diet a
compilation of no carb recipes but this
plate is low-key just carbs and i love
fruit but it's not surprising that it's
not the most satiating choice all on its
own so to turn into a hunger crushing
combo you could pair the apple with some
nut butter or some full fat greek yogurt
for dipping so i forgot to mention that
instead of doing the 40 minutes of
cardio every day we are going to be
doing an hour long class of hot yoga i
almost passed out this time but last
time the first time i ever came i
i saw black everything okay first of all
i guess bianca is just gonna do this
routine her way in her order of choice
and i respect that because there is no
point in torturing yourself more than
you need to for youtube views oh my god
a tortured artist i love that but also
it is never okay to almost pass out from
your activity basically what's happening
here is that her blood pressure is
likely dropping as her blood vessels
dilate in the heat so the best advice to
combat this is to make sure that you are
well hydrated ideally we want to replace
what we've lost in sweat so we can
assume that one kilogram of weight lost
during exercise can be replaced by one
to one and a half liters of water eating
regular meals throughout the rest of the
day will also help to replace any salt
loss but if you are finding that you're
like a salty sweater you can also add a
pinch of extra salt to your water and
your meals or consider an electrolyte
supplement i honestly didn't get to eat
lunch tea shake made me bloat so bad
you're not gonna be seeing me drink this
again in my video or ever again if you
are the type to just forget to eat
please
do your body a favor and plan ahead and
have some grab-and-go snacks that you
can just pop in your bag and take
wherever you're going things like
packaged nuts seeds fruit protein bars
or jerky are all really great
grab-and-go options second considering
that we just skipped lunch and like
straight up protein in milk is not an
adequate replacement for a meal i would
absolutely want to see some fiber and
more carbs in there for post-workout
recovery and also a little bit of fat as
well just bump up the satiety factor
third she mentioned bloating badly from
the shake and i want to discuss a few
reasons why that might be so this brand
of protein powder ghost is sweetened
with sucralose aka blender which some
folks may find to trigger gas and
bloating another very likely contributor
though is that she let herself get so
ravenously hungry she just gulped it
down and that extra air while chugging
actually can cause more bloating and
indigestion
here's the thin a lot of veggies and
protein oh my god this is bloody torture
and she's not doing her bloated belly
any favors with her choice and veg so
green bell peppers broccoli and onions
are all high fodmap options which can
cause serious gas and bloating for
sensitive folks so if you are sensitive
to some fodmaps easier on the gut
options include red bell peppers
zucchini carrots and fennel also i get
that it doesn't fit the no carb
lifestyle she's trying to emulate but
adding a source of carbs to this meal
can also often buffer some of the
irritating effects of fodmaps on the gut
am i full yes but am i to satisfy
because of the lack of the carbs on my
plate yes but i think it's just a mind
over matter thing yikes that's a red
flag this is the difference between
satisfaction and satiety both are
equally important when feeding yourself
fullness alone is not sustainable and is
typically a recipe for a binge i already
ate some fruit and nuts just because i
felt faint again red
flag an empty stomach is like our first
sign of normal biological hunger by the
time we're feeling faint our blood sugar
levels have likely dropped pretty low
now usually in a healthy person without
diabetes your body will have defense
mechanisms against this but some people
are very sensitive to these changes and
will feel hypoglycemia-like symptoms
like feeling light-headedness or dizzy
even if they're not below the clinical
threshold
[Music]
so i finished my lunch i'm sorry that
was lunch
what oh no oh my gosh this is hella
triggering this is bringing me back to
my oil phobic days when i would eat
vegetables for lunch with like fat-free
vinaigrette i'm not even sure where to
start this lunch has an insignificant 88
calories and no protein or fat to be
seen
is that all i would absolutely want to
see some chicken tofu or egg on top
along with some oil avocado nuts or
seeds for healthy fats i cracked last
night i ate a vitamin sandwich which has
bread and you're not supposed to have
any carbs so
i want to empathize with bianca here and
point out that she didn't crack or fail
this diet is borderline starvation let's
give our body some credit for fighting
to keep us in a healthy state
interestingly despite the remorse she
actually looks happier in this clip than
any of the other previous clips probably
because that carb boost helped to
increase the brain serotonin levels
producing a calming effect she may also
be getting some relief from the keto flu
which are the symptoms that a person
starting a very low carb diet can expect
to experience when you drastically lower
your carb intake your body needs to
adapt to using ketones as its energy
source and that transition often makes
you feel like
[Music]
oh gosh
not the celery juice juicy juicy juice
juice to juice i love you more than
anyone well i guess we're at least
getting some fiber and carbs in the day
with the smoothie but again if she has a
sensitive stomach the celery is also a
very high fodmap choice i think i'm
burning out my stomach has never been
this sore it's so sore and i'm getting
cramped they're not period cramps i
don't know what's going on but my body
is just telling me stop i am
unfortunately
not at all surprised there are a few
reasons here why she's probably feeling
like first of all it sounds to me like
she's suffering from overreaching so
overreaching is extreme muscle soreness
experienced when the body isn't given
the time it needs to recover between
training sessions this isn't super
painful but it can literally run you
down and over time it can result in
overtraining secondly if she does have
ibs she is definitely hitting those
fodmaps super hard so while the sauteed
veggies and celery smoothie are all
considered healthy foods they're all
rich in these fermentable carbohydrates
and when you fill that fodmap bucket too
full you're likely to feel bloated and
gassy as
finally she's grossly under eating when
your stomach is empty or when your
body's anticipating your next meal your
hunger hormone ghrelin is released so
ghrelin tells your stomach to produce
more stomach acid and also to move more
so if you don't eat the combination of
the extra acid and all that movement
causes those grumbles and stomach pains
also as i discussed in my video right
here an empty belly is a gassy belly so
for a lot of other reasons chronic under
eating can cause or exacerbate digestive
distress
[Music]
yes all right definitely relieved that
we got a little fat this time and some
chicken on top it's still probably not
very satiating because it's pretty low
calorie and it's low carb but certainly
a huge step up from her day two greens
fruit and nut butter is a great hunger
crushing combo snack now based on her
outline of alexa's diet at the start of
this video it's clear that bianca is
taking some creative liberties and thank
goodness for that at least we're getting
a little carbs in there to complement
that monotonous avocado egg and celery
smoothie breakfast that i just could not
ever accept was my life also guys i just
want to mention that whenever i'm hungry
i eat a fruit great we love to hear that
because our body thrives on carbs but i
just want to point out the health halo
that fruit has in some of these
carb-hating circles while grains are
demonized and restricted folks they're
all carbs in fact if we want to be
nitpickety a lot of the whole grains are
actually higher in fiber or lower on the
glycemic index when compared to some
fruits so for example a serving of
bulgur wheat has 4.1 grams of fiber and
has a glycemic index of 48 compared to
that thick slice of pineapple that she
added to her salad which only has 2.3
grams of fiber and has a glycemic index
of 66. see there is room for any and all
carbs on the plate wait i forgot to add
the chicken
now that looks better i feel like a
broken record but this is just not
enough it's one thing to cut out carbs
and transition to a keto diet where 70
to 80 percent of your total calories
would come from fats but it is quite
another to cut out carbs not replace
them with anything and then wind up
having 300 calorie meals when we looked
at this average day as a whole it was
clocking in at
350 calories what the actual
honestly yoga really made me detox
mentally i am more prepared to eat less
carbs like i said throughout the video i
always thought i had to eat a lot of
carbs to stay full and happy but i don't
i was really enjoying the veggies it
just really made me realize that i can
do it does anyone else
not feel convinced the girl didn't look
very happy and she admitted to caving to
eating a sandwich or a piece of fruit or
just skipping a meal if it wasn't
convenient for her this is clearly not a
sustainable diet and it's disappointing
to see this challenge positioned as
something to be proud of completing can
we stop glamorizing torturous starvation
regimens how painful is painful and
could any result possibly be worth the
agony here well let's find out 25 inches
so my waist remained 25 inches but i
lost half an inch off my lower belly
which i'm so proud of but i'm still very
happy with the result i hate to burst
her weight loss high but it's very
unlikely that she would have lost any
significant amount of actual fat in five
days so her measurement differences can
be explained by probably two main things
first is a loss of water weight from the
significant drop in carbs when you eat
carbs they get stored as glycogen in the
liver and muscles now glycogen holds
onto water about 1 gram of carbs to 3
grams of h2o so when you drain your
glycogen stores you lose a lot of water
along with it second she's consuming a
small volume of food so her stomach is
literally empty when you eat and drink
your stomach will expand and contract
throughout the day as it processes your
meals and drinks these fluctuations
don't represent increasing or decreasing
fat levels but really just gas food and
fluid movement if she resumes eating
carbs after this challenge her body will
store some of the carbs glycogen along
with its respective water weight and
she'll gain the inches and weight right
back so to wrap this up i think we can
all agree that this is not good
yep
yes as much as i am obsessed with
euphoria as a show i do think in a lot
of ways its aesthetic perpetuates and
glamorizes a very problematic body ideal
and the fact that this young content
creator emulated this extreme crash diet
and then patted herself on the back for
her results and for sticking to it for
like five days just further confirms
this problematic trend and i'm not
criticizing bianca i mean diet culture
is so pervasive it is impossible to
escape but when you see content like
this i hope my commentary can remind you
to scroll on by and on that note that is
all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who or what you'd like to see me
review next subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]